i ain't never really had nobody go like
really bad blood with me i feel like
there was a time wasn't there a time you
got in trouble for trying to go into the
locker room to fight somebody after a
game
oh nurkish nurkic
yeah that's
he was doing the nba talk
and i wasn't i wasn't trying to get the
on the court tech but it was like
it was just we ended up having a
conversation afterwards uh
um i believe i forgot who who set it up
for us but i ended up talking to him but
i think the next time we played or some
[ __ ] we squashed but it was a
i felt like some of the [ __ ] he was
doing and one of the things he said it
was like bro there's a slo-mo replay
like
you realize my daughter somebody on the
street might really think this is how
this go like yeah they might think they
really finna get this off and i'm
letting you know bro we don't get that
off like yeah
i told him when i was coming to the
locker room i told him on the court and
i think everybody thought because we won
i just was like gonna let it go
and i took off and went through the back
and you know what's crazy is
they made it a big thing like i walked
over there and people was like holding
me back and all this other [ __ ] and
it wasn't bro like i knew how to get
there through this
i went through the back locker room and
everything to where i just popped up and
i'm at this locker room g and i'm like
come out come out here and have a
conversation with me g for real i don't
even know if i was gonna fight him or
not all right
yeah we gotta have a talk bro cause
y'all just
this nba [ __ ] is y'all going too far bro
and i don't know
i don't know where we at like
you can't tell me it's on deck like that
and then
i get out the uber and you right there
bro cause once it's on deck it's on deck
so it's like i'm not you know what i'm
saying like i don't know how to do that
every time somebody told me it's on site
it was really on site that's real [ __ ]
and i'm fighting for you know what i'm
saying i'm not really just this ain't no
the teacher gonna break it up fight you
know what i'm saying it's like i haven't
been in a fight that took two minutes
long like you have been a fight check
two minutes bro it's the longest [ __ ] in
the world
two minutes is a long fight a long
streak
if you're fighting for 20 seconds it
feels it feels like an eternity yeah but
it's usually a fight nobody helping yeah
yeah it's like if ain't nobody help
ain't nobody here tonight two minutes
it's a very long fight so that's what
i'm thinking of i'm thinking more like
that right bro if we pop out in a club
what i'm supposed to just act like we
cool now like after you say some [ __ ]
like that like you do some [ __ ] like
that like he's
he was just like two
i don't know it was too like whatever
deal with it i'm like bro ain't no deal
with it like yeah i know and then he's
like saying a different language and
threw a couple of you know threw a
couple of american curse words at me i'm
sweaty i ain't going for that yeah i
don't like it that's all i ran back
there but i ain't never had nobody that
i'm like looking for in the league like
right right right i've never had nothing
like that um i just think he just took
it a little too far when he shouldered
me